okay today I'm going to talk to you
about the history of the utter because
as we know atoms are the tiny building
blocks the fundamental building blocks
of everything but because they're so
small we haven't always known their
exact structure so what we're going to
talk about is the kind of four different
models of the UH term and how they
changed our understanding of them
changed over time so a long time ago
a guy called John Dalton came up with
the first kind of proposed idea of an
atom with and all his idea was that they
were just made of simple small spheres
so they're essentially just these these
little spheres that made up everything
so that was the first one Dalton's model
now a little later in 1897
JJ Thompson came along and his work
showed something a little different now
what his work was called
he called it the plum pudding model and
the reason for this was his idea of the
atom looked a little bit like a plum
pudding what you heard is all of these
negative electrons within a plum pudding
of positive charge so is the idea that
his idea was most of the atom was
positive but we had these negative
electrons dotted throughout it like a
plum pudding now this this was how the
model was accepted for a while until
someone called Rutherford came along and
did a particularly famous study now what
he did is as we known now know and what
he found out is that the nucleus of an
atom is positive but the rest of it is
actually made of empty space or the
majority of it is made of empty space
because what he did is he fired these
things called alpha particles that have
a positive
charge now what he found is most of the
alpha particles went straight through
the atom this gate for him is first
finding that most of an atom is actually
made of empty space however some of
these alpha particles when they got near
to the nucleus because they're both
positive
they actually repelled so um this shown
him but by being able to detect these
alpha particles which repelled it gave
him second finding and that finding was
that there is a positive positive
nucleus so we could see so far how this
idea had evolved now the final one we
need to know about is the work of
someone called Baal now due to his him
providing lots and lots of experiments
and observations we now have this
understanding which we know for GCSE and
this understanding is that we have this
positive nucleus and then we have shells
electron shells around the outside and
like I said the way that ball managed to
come up with this model the idea that we
have this positive nucleus with
electrons shells around the outside was
because he carried out lots of
experiments and observations so in
science in order for work to be accepted
it needs to be peer reviewed so each
stage this work would have been reviewed
by other scientists to make sure that
their results match so just to summarize
the history of the atom just shows how
our understanding of the atom changed
over time initially Dalton thought that
atoms were just small spheres JJ
Thompson said it was more like a plum
pudding model with a big kind of
positive charge when electrons dotted
throughout like plums in a put in
Rutherford fired alpha particles to find
that
most of the atom was empty space and
that because some particles would were
repelled and has a positive nucleus and
finally Bohr came along did some
experiments and observations to find out
that an atom has a positive nucleus and
electron shells where the electrons are
found thank you